bonjour à tous donc bienvenue à cette
nouvelle édition de la fête de la nature
la 15e plus précisément donc qui est
organisé par conseil départemental en
association avec ses gestionnaires ses
partenaires qui gèrent les différents
espaces naturels sensibles de lille donc
là on est sur l'espace naturel sensible
de cap blanc qu'on appelle aussi le lsd
haut de la rivière langevin qui est
gérée par la fédération départementale
de pêche à la randonnée en elle même
elle relativement facile fait 5 km aller
retour on va faire aux alentours de 200
à 250 mètres de dénivelé positif et on
va d'abord traversé des parcelles
anciennement cultiver certaines qui sont
encore plus ou moins entretenues et plus
on va progresser dans le sentier on va
rentrer dans un milieu forestier de plus
en plus préservée après vous allez où
l'eau voilà elle est à une dizaine de
mètres sous nos pieds
[Musique]
et le problème avec les espèces
exotiques c'est que pour bon nombre
d'entre elles c'est elles sont devenues
envahissante
[Musique]
là on est au pied de grand coude dont on
a des vues aériennes c'est assez
impressionnant de voir cette route sur
un flanc de falaise
[Musique]
donc là on va en profiter pour sortir
momentanément du chantier allait dans
les lignes la rivière pour aller voir la
fameuse arche naturelle qu'on appelle le
bassin de la corbeille et donc après
chaque forte pluie
il se remplit complètement et déborde à
nouveau là où on se trouve
même le guide y fait les faits tout ouïe
on sent une petite claque dans laquelle
il ya une ou deux truites arc en ciel
qui sont en prisonnière glace qu'on va
faire avec l'association agréé pêche la
fédération départementale de pêche
c'est qu'on va intervenir pour récupérer
ces poissons là et les lâcher plus haut
dans une pension ou l'aude et pérenne et
ne s'infiltre pas dans le sol pour
éviter qu'elle meure asséché en partant
toujours attention ça glisse et on
arrive au point de vue de la cascade là
c'est juste là vous avez fait plus dur
donc ici nous trouvons devant notre
première parcelle de restauration
écologique elle cet arbre là l'arbre à
money drop terrain il faut pour garder
lever la tête vont jouer
ouais un petit sentier secret or là vous
avez participé à la plantation d'espèces
indigènes et endémiques
donc là on va mettre en terre comme tous
les autres visiteurs qui sont venus
durant la fête de la nature donc ces
sujets d'indigènes
ici on a un bois de nèfles et un boîte
de sureau et deux plans de mafate en
bois pour que les racines partent mieux
dans le sol et après on les plante
ensemble planter c'est la vie g je pense
mais voilà voir cet apprenti avant deux
ans je reviens
[Musique]
et puis ce qui est bien aussi c'est
avoir un guide et le guide du coup il
offre plus de possibilités on a beaucoup
plus d'informations et tout c'est
vraiment superbe et nous fait voir des
trucs qu'on voit pas forcément et son
intéressant c'est ça qui est intéressant
[Musique]
voilà qu'en toile à la nature émile
regard justement c'est ça aussi on peut
voir les grands panoramas l'on peut
s'arrêter sur des choses beaucoup plus
petit l infiniment petit avec des
insectes justement là on a vraiment
beaucoup de chance de tomber sur cette
petite mante religieuse
[Musique]
c'est ici que se termine la visite
j'espère que ça vous a plu
on propose des visites guidées toute
l'année pas que pendant la fête de la
nature et les week-ends nature donc les
gens peuvent me contacter directement à
l'association
l'association agréée de pêche et nous
nous réserver une visite guidée sur ce
il y en a qui disent qu'il n'y a pas
toutes des saisons à la réunion qu'on
n'a pas la l'automne à nous prouver le
contraire
la réunion aussi les faillites ont
[Musique]